on va repartir à new york il ya
l'ambassadeur russe auprès des nations
unies qui va s'exprimer
ce qui se passe en ukraine
est un leurre
prochaine ce projet possible
je vous demande pardon madame la
présidente
si vous nous lisez ce dernier
notre réunion d'aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que je n'entends pas
mon micro fans ne fonctionne pas mes
écouteurs
je ne fonctionne pas
toujours plus de madame la présidente
madame la présidente juste au dessus de
la
réunion d'aujourd'hui représente une
tentative de ce plus de la part des
autorités à qui avaient
commencé à mettre en vie mais une
hystérie artificielle sur ce qui se
passe en ukraine et leur un patron
occidentaux
encourager les soutiennent aujourd'hui
nous avons entendu des choses
informations sur
soi disant l'attaquant russe sur la
centrale nucléaire 1 2 après j ai tout
ceci est une attaque des informations
si il y avait des tirs de la part de la
russie sur cette centrale c
affabulation ne correspondent pas à la
réalité la ville d mergault d'art la
centrale nucléaire
zappa rosien et les environs ont été
prises sous le contrôle des militaires
russes en date du 28 février
suite aux
échanges et négociations avec le
personnel de cette centrale cette
centrale a été mise sous protection
militaire russe l'objectif est de ne pas
permettre
qu'un groupe marc
nationalistes aux terroristes aux autres
formations
comme illégitime de
créer des provocations ou à d'empêcher
l'approvisionnement en énergie c'est
vers les consommateurs européens
monsieur la centrale
nucléaire avec des amérindiens et les
environs et sous la protection des
militaires russes en ce moment et les
spécialistes notamment un qui s'y
connaissent bien dinard au
fonctionnement de la somme
sur la sûreté et il en est de même pour
la centrale de tchernobyl jusqu'au bout
la sécurité et la sûreté de ces sites
est assurée par les forces russes et par
les équipes d'opérateurs et craignant
sinon forces russes n'interfère pas au
fonctionnement des opérateurs locaux sur
place il assure juste
sécurité
ah bonjour maman aux informations
données par le ministère de la défense
1 il y a eu
une patrouille un hoquet
effectuer son travail et non pas sur la
centrale nucléaire mais aux environs de
cette centrale est un groupe 1 de
saboteurs ukrainien a attaqué la
patrouille russe et pour
provoquer le feu
réponse
sur à le l'endroit qui est rare à
l'extérieur de cette centrale à
les forces russes ont subi
des salvages de tirs et ont
riposté et donc non atteint ce bâtiment
d'entraînement où il y avait ces unités
ukrainienne qui
se tire a provoqué le feu dans ce
bâtiment mais le feu le bâtiment ne se
trouve pas sur le territoire de la
centrale les pompiers qui sont arrivés
rapidement sur place ont éteint le feu
et au moment de cette convocation
il n'y avait pas de personnel je la sens
sale dans le bâtiment qui servait de
centre de formation
le personnel de danse la centrale qui
n'a pas été blessé la différence de ce
que m'a dit la représentante des états
unis un hoax personnel mais les
opérateurs sont tenus à travailler sur
le site et un surveiller le niveau de
radioactivité le niveau de radioactivité
dans cette instruction dans ce site et
de la totalité des centrales nucléaires
est sous le contrôle que le contrôle est
assuré par les militaires russes le
fonctionnement de la centrale
déroule conformément
aux exigences et aux paramètres heureux
qu'ils aient les réacteurs n'ont pas été
endommagés le premier
est arrêté pour un réparation le
deuxième le troisième a été arrêté
selon as les décisions des
dirigeants très central si ça va un
mégawatt c'est la puissance d'un des
réacteurs qui fonctionne et qu'on fort
heureusement un rose informations
reçues l'a1 le fonctionnement 2 à ses
six réacteurs se déroule comme il se
doit la capacité de fonctionnement n'est
pas endommagé il n'y a pas de risque de
fuite radioactive
mais je tiens à vous rappeler qu'en 2014
les nationalistes ukrainiens avaient
déjà essayé de déstabiliser la situation
sur cette centrale datant de juillet est
là dans la ville des nerfs godard et les
états occidentaux avaient ignoré ce
car outrageux qui aurait pu être
potentiellement dangereux et nous avions
joué à ce moment là attirer l'attention
sur ce cas aujourd'hui et quand les
militaires russes feront tout le
nécessaire pour assurer est la sûreté la
sécurité des sites s indignent atomique
nucléaire en ukraine ne voyons donc
cette flambée de campagne de propagande
comme quoi de désinformation comme quoi
elle a réussi un soi-disant créerez ya
des
perturbations ou des points de départ de
feu armée qu'elle un objectif on aurait
pu avoir à quoi bon on aurait fait cela
nous ne pouvons
qu'être
des acteurs qui y
en ce qui concerne la sûreté et la
sécurité sur le nucléaire et les
installations nucléaires en ukraine eh
bien nous sommes les acteurs qui feront
tout ce qu'il faut pour assurer cette
sûreté et sécurité car nous sommes à
terme et à mon proche de tchernobyl et
nous sommes en plus que concernés et
intéressés par la sécurité et la sûreté
nucléaire je souligne une fois de plus
que ce n'est pas les forces
russes mais les nationalistes ukrainiens
qui un fond des actes de sabotage et de
provocation et là nous sommes en train
de parler d'un de ces cas rires ils
essaient de rejeter la faute sur la
partie russe je devrais donc ce qui
s'est passé sur cette centrale de
zaporijia en est un exemple flagrant il
vos tentatives n'a de faire un tout un
scandale international à bâtir deux
car
confirme que les extrémistes et les
nationalistes ukrainiens sont sous votre
patronage plein et entier et vous leur
donner carte blanche
et un pour tout cela on oublie le sort
des simples les ukrainiens comme pendant
les huit ans
vous oubliez
c'est là un les tâches de ce qu'elle
habitait dans une
autre
vie les
terroristes sont toujours en plus
accompagné peu différent un tentative de
mettre
du matériel lourd dans les quartiers
résidentiels
60 personnes à marioupol qui voulait
emprunter le couloir humanitaire ont été
transférés de force dans une école
cheminée donc les terroristes utilisent
acs civils comme boucliers humains
et 10 qui sèche
serait prêt à faire exploser mais quoi
la vie des otages les terroristes
empêchent les civils de quitter les
villes et non seulement les ukrainiens
souffre mais aussi les citoyens
étrangers et la quantité des étrangers
retenus par les nationalistes ukrainiens
choc
de 3000
et plus
à dire ceux retenus un quartier jeune il
ya des citoyens module maintien chinois
gagnent et qui sont retenus à dans
d'autres villes soumet
ses citoyens indonésiens qui sont
il y à des tirs sur les groupes des
citoyens l'étranger qui essaie de se
sortir de l'endroit dangereux pour
rejoindre par exemple la russie c'est
dangereux par exemple à belgorod sur le
point de passage sur rojas
à partir de 6 heures du matin il y à
50 bus qui sont un prêt à évacuer ses
citoyens étrangers vers la russie
sur les
[Musique]
passages il ya des
vivres et tout ce qu'il faut pour
ensuite les transporter à belgorod et
ensuite ils pourront reprendre les
transports aériens pour regagner leur
pays
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
encore un épisode outrage voudrions
recevoir plus d'informations le canal
itélé g de soi disant défense
territoriale de gramat tort ce qu a
publié un une missive comme quoi les
automobiles des représentants de
l'émission des nations unies ont été
réquisitionnés si vous n'êtes pas encore
nous sommes prêts à vous transmettre ses
informations et
publications on disait que le jectif
est plus important que les moyens le but
justifie les moyens et que c'est pour
cela que les véhicules ont misé ont été
réquisitionnés et nous n'avons pas vu de
réaction et de contestation 1200 du
désaccord
de la base des organes des nations unies
un quart et les trajets d'utiliser ce
moyen si c'est le cas si le secrétariat
des nations unies à taux courants comme
les nationalistes le 19 drion recevoir
que dans ce roman sur pourquoi l'onu
n'en avait pas informé les pays membres
je vous remercie
voilà on vient de voir en direct les
locutions devant le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu de l'ambassadeur russe auprès
des nations unies